what is our place called Geordie Shore a
Geordie it's a bit like a derogatory
name feel like I thought it was fake at
first because it sounds so close to
Jersey Shore
hey that's awful and everyone's watching
it we should do our version this program
contains strong language sexual scenes
what that is the most polite warning
I've ever heard there's the Snuggie this
is the English language I'm thankful for
this subtitle oh oh oh shoot balls are
out minute one gossiping in the house it
was bound to happen guff spin in the
house a bone to happen I mean he looks
like he could be from the shore it I'm
lying there banging this blonde do you I
didn't understand a word of that can we
also just backtracked and talk about
like how we just saw dick like on TV I
don't think you could get away with that
here no we don't get balls you know me a
boob oh yeah that looks like JWoww and
that looks like Pauly D there all
shirtless that's exactly like Jersey
Shore the fight just broke out
yeah is there a tent yeah this is what
the English are about what was it about
what was the argument about the women
looked like a drunk person withdrawing
an anime character
this makes Jersey Shore look scripted
you're really she said Willy in a
serious sentence trying desperately to
get a shot in the shagged that's a word
we don't really say I love Charlotte is
cuckoo
I think someone's drinking a full bottle
of wine on their own oh they just need
to take away like all throwable objects
in this house
I like Charlotte I'm so invested I need
to know what happens not Charlotte I
don't like sorry little Charlotte was
just drinking a bottle of wine with a
straw so that's cool without the straw
out of control
Charlotte is now fighting security
guards you slag
I'm learning colorful new insult yeah I
need a shower
I love this it's like Jersey Shore on
steroids I know that you're not all like
this do you think the Queen of England
likes this yeah
there's always gonna be a handful of
people that like to be insane there's
nothing wrong with that because we all
need good TV